I think I started programming around the end of 2022. I started with Python. Then a year after that, somewhat, I started getting into C++. And then middle of 2024, I discovered Cuda. And that's, I got really into Cuta. And then I did my master thesis in Cuda. I, after that, June of last year, I started an internship at Nvidia. And then that was until December.
我想我是从2022年底左右开始编程的。我从Python开始。然后大约一年后，我开始接触C++。接着在2024年中期，我发现了Cuda，然后，我迷上了Cuda，并用Cuda做了我的硕士论文。之后，在去年六月，我在英伟达开始了一份实习，一直持续到十二月。
And then in February, I've started as a full-time employee, as a software engineer. on the NVCOM library team, so maintaining that library. And that's basically my path to where I am now. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast, episode 283 recorded on April 23, 2006. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host, Bryce, we interview a fellow NVIDian Marco Salgado. This will probably be part one of a three or four-part conversation. In this first part, we primarily talk about Marco's path to Nvidia, where he started.
然后在二月份，我作为一名全职员工开始担任软件工程师，加入NVCOM库团队，负责维护该库。基本上，这就是我走到今天的路径。欢迎收听ADSP播客，第283集，录制于2006年4月23日。我是康纳，今天我和我的联合主持人布莱斯一起采访了英伟达的同仁马尔科·萨尔加多。这可能是三到四部分对话的第一部分。在第一部分中，我们主要讨论马尔科加入英伟达的路径，以及他从哪里开始。
with zero programming experience less than three and a half years ago and ended up with a full-time position at NVIDIA. I should also say I was supposed to announce at the beginning, but now I guess I have to cut this in. If you are listening to this in the first three days from when this comes out tomorrow, which for you is today listening to it, on April 27th, if you happen to be in Toronto, there is a, the first in like many years, C++, Toronto user group meeting, which I'll be speaking at. I flew back, you know, Shanghai, Hong Kong, Hong Kong to New York, and that is east to west. Ramona flew back Shanghai to Dubai and then she spent a day doing stuff in Dubai and then Dubai to New York. My question is not why she's not with you. My question is, why are you picking her up? Because the last time I checked, you don't have a car. I mean, this is just, this is just what you do.
在不到三年半前带着零编程经验开始，最终在英伟达获得了全职职位。我还应该说，我本该在开头宣布的，但现在我想我得把这段剪进去了。如果你在明天发布的头三天内听到这个——对你来说是今天听到——在4月27日，如果你碰巧在多伦多，将会有一个，多年来的第一个，C++多伦多用户组会议，我将在那里发言。我飞回去了，你知道，上海、香港，香港到纽约，那是东向西。拉莫娜飞回上海到迪拜，然后她在迪拜花了一天时间做事情，然后迪拜到纽约。我的问题不是她为什么不跟你在一起。我的问题是，你为什么要接她？因为据我上次检查，你没有车。我的意思是，这只是，这只是你做的事。
Connor, you pick up, when your partner returns from a long trip, you go to the airport and you meet them with flowers. What? This is like boyfriend one-on-one, 101. Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa. What she, how are you getting to the airport? I'm going to take the train. She's got bags and she doesn't like traveling on her own. So you meet her at the airport.
康纳，你去接，当你的伴侣从漫长的旅程中回来时，你去机场，带着花去迎接他们。什么？这就像男朋友入门101，101。哇，哇，哇，哇。她，你怎么去机场？我要坐火车。她有行李，她不喜欢自己一个人旅行。所以你去机场接她。
What, she's going to have to go and figure out where to get a cab on her own. It's called Uber. You hit a button on your phone and it shows that is, wow, you are quite the gentleman. I mean, because how long have you guys been dating? You've been dating for, I want to say five years. I'm actually, for once, I'm banking on immigration, taking a long time to process it like they usually do. All right. So we don't have time.
什么，她得自己去找地方打车吗？这叫Uber。你在手机上按一个按钮，它就会显示，哇，你真是一个绅士。我的意思是，你们约会多久了？你们约会了，我想说五年。实际上，破天荒地，我押注移民局会像往常一样处理很长时间。好吧。所以我们没有时间。
We have like a whole, I've gone down like a very deep AI rabbit hole. And like, I think I've leaped for, I sent you on Slack. I think I've leapfrogged you on a couple things. All right, we've got to take a step back. This is classic Bryce, though. He, like, jumps into the middle of, like, a conversation that we haven't even started. And he's like, all, right, right, right, right, we got this. So we have a guest with us, first of all.
我们就像有一个整体，我掉进了一个非常深的AI兔子洞里。而且，我想我已经飞跃了，我在Slack上发给你了。我觉得我在好几件事上都超越了你。好吧，我们得退一步。不过，这很典型布莱斯。他就像，跳到了我们甚至还没开始的对话中间，然后他说，好，好，好，好，我们搞定这个。所以首先我们有一位嘉宾。
So what we're going to do is we're going to introduce our guest. And then we are going to talk about the couple, maybe more than a couple topics that you're going to hear over the next two to three to four episodes. We're probably going to record this in two parts, though, because we've got, I think, only 40, maybe 50, depending, depending on. on the status of Ramona's progress through immigration. And anyway, so what we talk about in this first episode, I don't actually know which topic we're going to cover first. But we'll introduce Marco in a second. The topics we're going to talk about, I believe, are Bryce's leaping Connor and his AI
所以我们要做的就是介绍我们的嘉宾。然后我们要谈论这几对，也许不仅仅是一对话题，你将在接下来的两到三到四集里听到这些话题。不过，我们可能会把这个录成两部分，因为我们有，我想，只有40个，也许50个，取决于，取决于拉莫娜通过移民局进度的状态。不管怎样，所以在第一集中我们讨论的内容，我实际上不知道我们要先涵盖哪个话题。但我们一会儿会介绍马尔科。我们要谈论的话题，我相信是布莱斯的跳跃康纳和他的AI
abilities with his auto coupa and everything else he's been up to. Plus maybe some Bryce updates because he's been all over the world at different, I don't know, conferences, universities, doing lectures and talks. I don't actually know. He'll tell us. Will that be in the second part, the third part, or the first part? We don't know. And then the other thing we're going to, the other major topic we're going to be talking about is GPU implementation of an algorithm we talked about.
能力以及他的自动库帕和他的其他成就。加上一些布莱斯的更新，因为他一直在世界各地参加不同的，我不知道，会议、大学，做讲座和演讲。我其实不知道。他会告诉我们的。那会在第二部分、第三部分还是第一部分？我们不知道。然后我们要做的另一件事，我们要谈论的另一个主要话题是我们讨论过的一个算法的GPU实现。
I don't know what episode it was on, folks. Maybe Marco does. Of Rotate, which we. I think 200, 102. There's a couple of them there where you mentioned that in the episodes with Jared Weber. He knows the episode. You also talk about that. Well, that's the reason.
我不知道那是哪一集，各位。也许马尔科知道。关于Rotate的，我们。我想是200，102。在那几集里，你和杰瑞·韦伯一起讨论过这个问题。他知道那一集。你也谈到了那个。好吧，这就是原因。
on the slides that I presented, I mentioned one of the episodes. That's why I know that. So we'll let Marco introduce him in a second, but the way that this episode or these ADSP episodes came together is I've missed the last two Better Code meetings, which is an internal meeting at Nvidia that happens, I believe, every Wednesday or every other Wednesday that Jake Hempstead, I think is in charge of, but he might have actually delegated running it to a couple people on his team. Jake is a manager of the CCCL team, which is the Cuta Core Libraries, Kuta Core Compute Library. See, that's the beautiful thing about that acronym. Yes, change. You stand for whatever you wanted to stand for. The C has changed from time to time, but it is currently the first CQA.
在我展示的幻灯片上，我提到了其中一集。这就是为什么我知道。所以我们一会儿让马尔科自我介绍，但这一集或这些ADSP集之所以走到一起，是因为我错过了过去两次Better Code会议，这是英伟达内部的一个会议，我相信每个星期三或每隔一个星期三举行一次，杰克·汉普斯特德我想是负责人，但他实际上可能已经把运行工作委派给了他团队的几个人。杰克是CCCL团队的经理，也就是Cuta核心库，Kuta核心计算库。看，这就是那个缩写的美妙之处。是的，改变。它代表你想让它代表的任何东西。C时不时地在变，但它目前是第一个CQA。
It was Cuta Core compute libraries. No, I thought originally it was C++. C++, yes. No, no, no. Originally, I told people it was C++, but it was really Cuta core compute libraries. All right, right, we got what? It doesn't matter. We got, like I said, we're short on time, so we can't tell all these stories.
它是Cuta核心计算库。不，我以为最初是C++。C++，是的。不，不，不。最初，我告诉人们它是C++，但实际上它是Cuta核心计算库。好吧，好吧，我们得到了什么？没关系。我们有，就像我说的，我们时间紧迫，所以我们不能讲完所有这些故事。
But I missed the last two. One was on a find-if implementation, a GPU find-if. And the second one, the most recent one, was a rotate. And I actually had planned to go to that one, but a story we don't have time to tell the day is that my sump pump pipe, like, exploded. And that morning, like, I came downstairs in the basement to see water shooting out of the floor. I actually was at my desk at 5 p.m. Eastern time when that meeting was taking place. But just because the pipes had exploded, it rattled me and I missed that meeting. But then I was like, oh, yeah, better code was today.
但我错过了最后两次。一次是关于find-if实现的，一个GPU find-if。第二次，最近的一次，是一个rotate。我其实计划去参加那个，但有一个我们今天没时间讲的故事，那就是我的污水泵管道，像，爆炸了。那天早上，我下楼来到地下室，看到水从地板上喷出来。事实上，当那个会议进行时，我在东部时间下午5点坐在我的办公桌前。但仅仅是因为管道爆炸了，把我吓坏了，我错过了那个会议。但后来我想，哦，对了，Better code是今天。
I checked it like 10 p.m. And then I saw that I didn't know what the topic was. I saw that the topic was a rotate implementation. And I was like, oh, my goodness, I can't believe I miss this. And I also saw it was two hours. And I was like, holy smokes, it actually wasn't two hours. It was an hour. And then I believe, I think I'll throw them under the bus.
我在晚上10点左右查了一下。然后我看到我不知道主题是什么。我看到主题是一个rotate实现。然后我想，哦，天哪，我真不敢相信我错过了这个。我还看到它是两个小时。然后我想，天哪，它其实不是两个小时。是一个小时。然后我相信，我想我会把他们推到公交车下面。
Andrei Alexandrescu didn't log off of the meeting for an additional 60 minutes. So it's just his little icon. He has an excuse. The thing is that he had to basically leave the meeting because he had to take his kid to soccer practice or something. So he basically told me, yeah, I'll just stay in the meeting so that it keeps recording. And then everyone just locks off. So that's basically the reason.
安德烈·亚历山德雷斯库在会议结束后又多呆了60分钟才登出。所以这只是他的小图标。他有一个借口。事情是这样的，他基本上不得不离开会议，因为他得带孩子去踢足球练习什么的。所以他基本上告诉我，是的，我会留在会议里，这样它就能继续录音。然后每个人都登出了。所以基本上就是这个原因。
Was he the one that started the recording? Yeah, exactly. Oh, I see, I see. All right, that's fair enough, fair enough. You got to pick up your kids. You got to pick up your wife. you got to pick up your wife. A lot of people you got to pick up.
他是开始录音的那个人吗？对，没错。哦，我明白了，我明白了。好吧，那很公平，那很公平。你得去接你的孩子。你得去接你的妻子。你得去接你的妻子。有很多人需要你去接。
Anyway, so I saw that at 10 p.m. And I can't remember if I immediately watched it or I waited to first thing Thursday morning. And then I thought to myself, I did not understand a lot of stuff that was talked about in this session. And plus, even if I had understood everything, we got to bring Marco on. So with that all out of the way, we'll throw it over to you, Marco, because I actually, I don't think we've crossed paths before this. And introduce yourself. Tell us a little bit about your history, your path to Nvidia. and then we can decide do we defer GPU rotate to part two and get Bryce's Auto Kuda and travel updates or we do to the rotate now.
不管怎样，我在晚上10点看到了。我不记得我是立即观看的，还是等到周四一大早。然后我心想，这次会议中讨论的很多东西我都听不懂。而且，即使我都听懂了，我们也得把马尔科请来。所以这一切都抛开后，我们把它交给你，马尔科，因为事实上，我想我们在此之前没有交集。请自我介绍一下。向我们介绍一下你的历史，你通往英伟达的路径，然后我们可以决定是将GPU rotate推迟到第二部分，并了解布莱斯的Auto Kuda和旅行更新，还是我们现在就做rotate。
I don't know. We're going to talk about rotate this week because by next week, by next week, by next week coming. The whole will happen by next week. You're what is it? You're the Thanos collecting infinity rings and you've got like four out of five right now. That is correct. I have four out of five. All right.
我不知道。我们这周要谈论rotate，因为到下周，到下周，到下周来临时。全部都会在下周发生。你是什么？你是收集无限宝石的灭霸，现在你已经集齐了五分之四。没错。我有五分之四。好吧。
So Marco, throw it over to you. introduce yourself and then we'll yeah we'll talk about GPU rotate yeah so yeah mark i'm a fellow listener of the adsp podcast and yeah i'm 25 years old i'm from madrid spain originally but i studied in germany and i think i started programming around the end of 2022 i started with python then a year after that somewhat i started getting into c++ and then middle of 2024, I discovered Kuda, and that's, I got really into Kuda, and then I did my master thesis in Kuda. I, after that, June of last year, I started an internship at NVIDIA, and then that was until December, and then in February, I've started as a full-time employee, as a software engineer
所以马尔科，交给你了。自我介绍一下，然后我们，是的，我们会谈论GPU rotate。是的，所以，是的，马克，我是ADSP播客的另一位听众，是的，我25岁，我原籍西班牙马德里，但我曾在德国学习，我想我是从2022年底左右开始编程的，我从Python开始，然后大约一年后，我开始接触C++，接着在2024年中期，我发现了Cuda，然后，我迷上了Cuda，并用Cuda做了我的硕士论文。在那之后，在去年六月，我在英伟达开始了一份实习，一直持续到十二月，然后在二月份，我作为一名全职员工开始担任软件工程师
on the NVCOM library team, so maintaining that library, and that's basically my path to where I am now. hear what NVCOMP is. Also, you may be the youngest, the youngest guest on our, or the first post-COVID programmer on our podcast. And wait, before we get to MVP comp, I got 100 questions. This is like a, I don't want to say like regs to riches story, but you started programming like three and a half years ago and now you're working at Nvidia. Like, that's absurd.
在NVCOM库团队，负责维护该库，基本上，这就是我走到现在的路径。听到NVCOMP是什么。另外，你可能是我们节目中最年轻的，最年轻的嘉宾，或者说是我们播客上的第一位后疫情程序员。等等，在我们谈论MVP comp之前，我有100个问题。这就像一个，我不想说是灰姑娘式的逆袭故事，但你大约三年半前才开始编程，现在你在英伟达工作。这太荒谬了。
Well, first of all, what were you doing before then? And second of all, like, what are to tell the listeners, well, I guess maybe most of the listeners are gamefully employed, but to the ones that aren't her that are university students, how does one start programming and then rapidly go through Python C++ Kuda and get a job at Nvidia? That's wild. Yeah, that sounds well to me as well. Yeah. So basically I did my bachelor's in mechanical engineering. And I would say my first passion was aerodynamics. And so that's where I started. And then I did my master's in aerospace engineering. But I basically went to a specific university where you could choose a lot of different subjects. Because right after I began my master's, that's when I got started into programming and I really liked it. So I didn't know if I wanted to stay in aerodynamics or go into programs. And so that master's basically allowed you to do, I don't know, I did courses on quantum computing, on algorithms, on probabilistic and Monte Carlo methods, like weird stuff. Basically, you could choose between a lot of stuff. And then, yeah, basically, I also got a part-time job as a programmer in Python, and then that's also where I learned a lot of stuff. And then early on, I realized that I really enjoyed this and basically got obsessed with it. And that's how that went.
首先，你之前在做什么？其次，对于听众，好吧，我想可能大部分听众都有很好的工作，但对于那些没有工作或者是大学生的听众来说，一个人是如何开始编程，然后迅速经历Python、C++、Cuda并在英伟达找到工作的？这太疯狂了。是的，对我来说这也听起来很疯狂。是的。所以基本上我读的是机械工程学士学位。我想我的第一个激情是空气动力学。所以这就是我的起点。然后我读了航空航天工程硕士。但我基本上去了一所可以让你选择很多不同科目的特定大学。因为就在我开始硕士学位后不久，我开始接触编程，我真的很喜欢它。所以权不知道自己是想留在空气动力学领域还是进入编程领域。所以那个硕士学位基本上允许你做，我不知道，我上了量子计算、算法、概率和蒙特卡罗方法等 weird（古怪）课程。基本上你可以在很多东西之间进行选择。然后，是的，基本上，我还找了一份Python程序员的兼职工作，这也是我学到很多东西的地方。然后很早就，我意识到我真的很喜欢这个，并且基本上对它着迷了。事情就是这样发展的。
And then, yeah, when I got to C++, I got another job. I switched jobs to another part-time job as a C++ programmer. And I think that also helped me a lot because I went into a team that was developing a library where they were going to sell the source code itself. And so they really took care that everything was programmed very well and very clean style, very clean way of programming. And I learned a lot there. And then, yeah, I mean, when I got into Cuda, I think I was also very naive.
然后，是的，当我接触到C++时，我得到了另一份工作。我换了一份工作，担任C++程序员的兼职工作。我认为这对我帮助很大，因为我进入了一个正在开发一个将出售源代码本身的库的团队。所以他们非常注意确保一切编程都非常好，风格非常干净，编程方式非常干净。我在那里学到了很多。然后，是的，我的意思是，当我接触到Cuda时，我当时也很天真。
and I basically got destroyed at the beginning with the complexities, but I just kept on going, kept on going. And then my master thesis, I also had the fortune or like the good luck that I found a very good supervisor who's a professor at Texas State University, and he allowed me to do the master thesis with him. And I also learned a lot from that master's thesis. And then, yeah, and then the internship, everything also lined up. I think my supervisor is someone that is somewhat well known in the data compression space,
我一开始基本上被复杂性摧毁了，但我只是不断前进，不断前进。然后我的硕士论文，我也很有运气或说走运，我找到了一个非常好的导师，他是德州州立大学的教授，他允许我和他一起做硕士论文。我也从那篇硕士论文中学到了很多。然后，是的，然后是实习，一切都很顺利。我认为我的导师在数据压缩领域是某个小有名气的人。
in the GPU data compression space. So him giving good feedback on my work, I think also helped a lot for me to get the internship on Nvidia. And then once I was in Nvidia, I think it was just showing that I was good enough. And then I guess that was the way that I got in. I think doing an internship seems like a very good way of getting in because Nvidia seems to be a company that either only hires interns or all. only hire senior people. There's like a gap in between where new graduates don't really,
在GPU数据压缩领域。所以他对我的工作的良好反馈，我认为对我在英伟达获得实习机会也起到了很大帮助。一旦我进入英伟达，我认为这只是展示了我足够优秀。然后我想这就是我进入的方式。我认为实习似乎是一个很好的进入途径，因为英伟达似乎是一家要么只招实习生，要么只招资深人士的公司。中间有一个空白，新毕业生真的没有，
there are not really options for that. So I think an internship is a very good way for someone young to get into Nvidia. I think a lot of companies are like that. I mean, they would deny that they are, but it's just a matter of that it's, you're taking a risk. Like, it's a more certain thing if an intern has proven themselves and like a senior person has proven themselves. And so I do know that like new grads do get hired. But it is just, much more difficult. Like the company that I got hired at, they had like a massive funnel of basically co-op students and interns. And like it wasn't, this may be changing because I, when I was in China, I met with one of the most AI-pilled teams at Nvidia. And the manager of the team was saying,
真的没有这方面的选择。所以我认为实习对年轻人来说是进入英伟达的一个很好的途径。我认为很多公司都是这样的。我的意思是，他们会否认他们是这样的，但这只是一个承担风险的问题。就像，如果一个实习生已经证明了自己，一个资深人士已经证明了自己，这是一件更确定的事情。所以我确实知道应届毕业生会被录用。但这只是难得多。就像我被录用的公司一样，他们有庞大的合作学生和实习生漏斗。而且这并不是，这可能会改变，因为我，当我在中国时，我遇到了英伟达最痴迷AI的团队之一。团队经理说，
I only hire, I love interns. I only hire interns in new college grads. I have a bunch of senior roles that I can't fill because all the senior people are not like sufficiently AI-pilled. And so I don't want to hire a senior person when I can just keep hiring more junior people. And like that does kind of make sense to me. The other good way to get hired at NVIDIA is be a student at the University of Waterloo and do crazy, you know, cool AI stuff and then tweet about it. And there's like three or four of these students who have come across my desk recently. And I don't know what's going on with this current class of the University of Waterloo,
我只招人，我喜欢实习生。我只招实习生和应届大学毕业生。我有很多高级职位无法填补，因为所有高级人员都不够“AI狂热”。所以我不想招一个资深人士，如果我可以继续招更多初级人员的话。这对我来说确实说得通。在英伟达被录用的另一个好方法是成为滑铁卢大学的学生，做疯狂的、酷炫的AI东西，然后在推特上发出来。最近有三四个这样的学生进入了我的视线。我不知道滑铁卢大学这一届怎么了，
but they're all really, really sharp. I mean, it's always been the case, University of Waterloo, a great school. But yeah. Did the guy that implemented Herbal Quant get a position at Envidio or what? Not comment. Can't comment on that. Yeah. Any and I are chatting.
但他们都非常、非常敏锐。我的意思是，滑铁卢大学一直是一所伟大的学校。但确实。实现Herbal Quant的那个人在Envidio找到工作了吗？无可奉告。对此无可奉告。是的。我和任何人在聊天。
So wait, a couple more questions because I do find this very curious. You mentioned so you were based in Madrid, then you studied in Germany, but then you mentioned your thesis for your master's was at Texas State, A&M. I know there's a bunch of, I'm not sure if I got, did I get that right? Texas State. It's Texas State University. It's a different one from A&M. Okay.
等等，还有几个问题，因为我确实觉得这很奇怪。你提到你曾在马德里，然后在德国学习，但接着你提到你的硕士论文是在德州州立大学，A&M。我知道有一堆，我不确定我是不是，我记对了吗？德州州立大学。它是德州州立大学。它和A&M不同。好的。
Yeah, yeah, I know that, because there's like three of them. There's also like UT Austin anyways, and I always get them confused. So it's just Texas State. Were you still in Germany at the time, or did you come to the U.S. for your, how did that work? No, we did it remotely. So, I mean, I, yeah, when I did my master teachers, I went back to Madrid because it was in the winter, and winter in Germany is pretty miserable. So I took the chance, and I went back to Madrid, and I've been in Madrid ever since. So this was end of 2024.
是的，是的，我知道，因为大约有三个。还有UT奥斯汀之类的，我总是把它们搞混。所以它只是德州州立大学。你当时还在德国吗，还是你为了这个来到了美国，那是怎么运作的？不，我们是远程进行的。所以，我的意思是，当我做硕士论文时，我回到了马德里，因为那是冬天，德国的冬天相当悲惨。所以我抓住了机会，回到了马德里，从那以后我一直待在马德里。所以这是2024年底。
And so were you doing your master's just remotely from Texas state or did the Germany University have some like partnership or something? No, it's not necessarily a partnership. But I mean, in my experience, German universities are very flexible with how you do things. And so I basically just found someone at the German university that allowed me to have an external supervisor. And so I just did my thesis remotely from Madrid with my supervisor in Texas. We just had one Zoom call every week talking about stuff and then we emailed.
所以你只是从德州州立大学远程攻读硕士学位，还是德国的那所大学有什么合作关系？不，不一定是合作关系。但在我的经验中，德国大学在事情的处理上非常灵活。所以我基本上只是在德国大学找了一个允许我有外部导师的人。所以我只是在马德里远程完成了我的论文，我的导师在德州。我们每周只通过一次Zoom通话讨论事情，然后发邮件。
And then the guy from Germany just had to basically sign off the thesis saying that. You tell me that Germans are known for their flexibility. I know, I know. It doesn't sound right. But in my experience with university, they are pretty flexible. I mean, even in university, if you want to do your bachelor's in seven years, you can do it in seven years. It's your choice. You can choose how many courses you take every year. You can take during your first year. You can take courses from the third year if you want. You can do everything basically as you wish. It's your own problem. And I'm just going to say, please, no angry,
然后德国的那个人基本上只需在论文上签字说。你告诉我德国人以灵活性闻名。我知道，我知道。这听起来不对。但在我大学的经历中，他们相当灵活。我的意思是，即使在大学里，如果你想用七年时间读完学士学位，你也可以用七年时间。这是你的选择。你可以选择每年修多少门课。你可以在第一年修。如果你愿意，你可以修第三年的课程。基本上你可以随心所欲地做所有事情。这是你自己的问题。我只想说，请不要为此收到德国人生气的信。
no angry letters for that from the Germans. I guess last question, unless Bryce has got more questions about the education, because I find this very fascinating. And also, this is, I think, very valuable. Or maybe Europeans already are aware of this kind of flexibly. ability. But when you were searching for your thesis advisor, were you specifically at that point, did you have like CUDA in mind and potential like jobs in this space? And did you reach out specifically to that thesis advisor because of that? Or was it for other reasons you reached out? And then that kind of path just led to CUDA and Nvidia. No, so I, so basically I started with CUDA beginning of 2024 middle of 2034 in a university project and after getting into that I knew that
我想最后一个问题，除非布莱斯还有关于教育的更多问题，因为我觉得这非常迷人。而且这也是，我认为非常有价值的。或者也许欧洲人已经意识到这种灵活性了。但当你寻找论文导师时，你当时是否有特定的目标，比如脑海中有CUDA和这个领域的潜在工作？你是因为这个专门联系那个论文导师的吗？还是由于其他原因你联系了他？然后这种路径才引领你走向CUDA和英伟达。不，所以，基本上我在2024年初到2034年中期通过一个大学项目开始接触CUDA，在接触了这个之后，我知道
I wanted to do my master thesis in that and I think doing a master thesis in kuda is quite difficult it's quite difficult to find topics for it and research groups that specialize in that and so I basically started looking all over europe to see what options there were and then I came across some papers from him I think I had come across a paper from him already in the past and so I contacted him His name is Martin Burtcher. And then I just contacted him, sent in an email, and he was kind enough to, yeah, give me an opportunity. And that's basically how it happened. This is a, that's an amazing.
我当时想用它来做我的硕士论文，我觉得在 CUDA 领域做硕士论文挺难的，很难找到相关的课题和专门的研究小组，所以我基本上把整个欧洲都找遍了，看看有什么选择。后来我看到了他的一些论文，我想我以前可能就读过他的一篇论文，于是我联系了他。他叫马丁·布尔切（Martin Burtscher）。然后我就联系了他，发了一封电子邮件，他非常友好地，嗯，给了我一个机会。事情基本上就是这样发生的。这真的，太棒了。
I don't know if this exists in North America, but what a life hack. Like, I'm not sure if you had a mentor or something that told you this is possible. But, like, if you just stumbled onto this or maybe it's just a common thing, that is, like, wildly, like, I don't know, like, amazing. Or just, like, a focused, like, you wanted to go a place. you didn't find any advisors, you know, and so you just searched basically the globe, tried to find folks that were doing research in this area, found one, got them to agree to be your advisor. Note to like listeners that are, because we, like, probably one of the most common
我不知道北美有没有这种事，但真是一个生活小妙招。我是说，我不确定你是不是有什么导师或者什么人告诉你这是可能的。但如果你只是偶然碰上了这个，或者也许这很常见，那也真是，呃，非常，怎么说呢，太棒了。或者说，目标很明确，你想去某个地方，找不到导师，你知道的，所以你就搜遍了全球，试图找到在这个领域做研究的人，找到一个，让他们同意做你的导师。给听众们的提醒是，因为我们，就像，可能最常见的一个
questions we get is whether how do you get a job in Nvidia or like some other big tech company. And it's, and one of the things we always say is like, well, what do you want to do? And it sounds like you answered that question like very quickly, or at least at some point and then went and like found someone to basically do master's with. But that is very fascinated by that story. And I imagine there's a few people listening right now thinking like, huh, I'm in my fourth year of university.
我们收到的问题是，如何进入英伟达或其他大型科技公司工作。其中一个我们常说的是，好吧，你想做什么？听起来你很快就回答了这个问题，或者至少在某个时候想明白了，然后去找了个人一起攻读硕士学位。我对这个故事非常着迷。我想现在肯定有一些听众在想，嗯，我正读大四。
What a interesting idea. You know, maybe they're going to go do the same thing. All right. Any follow-up questions from Bryce? And also, too, actually, I do have one more question. You took a whole undergraduate degree in mechanical engineering. Was that the right engineering? And they didn't have a single programming assignment or programming course or anything like that?
真是个有趣的想法。你知道，也许他们也会去做同样的事情。好了，布莱斯还有什么后续问题吗？而且，其实我还有一个问题。你读的是整个机械工程本科专业。那是正确的工程学吗？而且他们连一个编程作业、编程课程都没有吗？
They had a course on programming. that was Java. I think it was second year or third year. And I remember that was very basic. I remember even the exam, you had to write code by hand. Oh, so that is a mandatory course. So you did take one course, but the problem was it was in Java, and that did not make you fall in love with it.
他们有一门编程课，是用 Java 学的。我记得那是大二或大三的时候。我记得那非常基础，我甚至记得考试时你必须手写代码。哦，所以那是一门必修课。所以你确实上过一门课，但问题是那是 Java，而这并没有让你爱上它。
Nah, the thing is I was already in love with aerodynamics, I guess. So it was hard for me to dedicate a lot of time to that because I was very focused on aerodynamics. Right. I see. So it wasn't until later until you came to programming. a second time that you kind of fell in love with it. Yeah, exactly.
不，其实我当时已经爱上空气动力学了，我猜是这样。所以我很难花很多时间在那上面，因为我太专注于空气动力学了。原来如此。我明白了。所以直到后来，当你第二次接触编程时，你才算是爱上了它。对，完全是这样。
Interesting. All right, any questions from Bryce, and then we can pivot to GP2, GPT. That's how AI build I am, folks. I can't say GPU correctly. No, no, no, no, let's talk about GPU rotate. All right. Well, throw it over to Marco. So, I mean, my, I thought the presentation was great.
有趣。好吧，布莱斯还有什么问题吗？然后我们可以转向 GP2，GPT。这就是我构建 AI 的水平，各位。我连 GPU 都念不对。不，不，不，不，我们来谈谈 GPU 旋转。好吧，交给马可。所以，我的意思是，我觉得这个演示棒极了。
There was, I mean, I'll let you explain the two different. I should, I have not seen this presentation because I was in China. So I have very limited background on this. And also the listening to those too. I mean, I guess we can't. You'll have to submit some version of all the version of this once GPU rotate gets into Thrust or Cub or wherever we're going to put it somewhere in CCCL and give it at a conference because probably we can't make that internal talk public.
那个，我的意思是，我让你来解释这两种不同的。我应该，我还没看这个演示，因为我在中国。所以我对这个了解非常有限。还有听这两个人的。我的意思是，我想我们不能。等 GPU 旋转进入 Thrust、Cub 或者我们将它放入 CCCL 的某个地方后，你得提交某个版本的这个演示，并在某个会议上讲一下，因为我们可能无法公开那场内部演讲。
But anyways, you present two different kind of implementations based on a criteria. But then the thing that I, you know, this might end up in like part two of this conversation. So a week from now. is like all the profiling and you were doing a ton of stuff with, I believe, NCU to like measure this metric and this metric. And like that stuff is just like I use NSIS, not all the time, but pretty frequently. It's NICU, not N-C-O. Is it N-C-U?
但无论如何，你根据某种标准展示了两种不同种类的实现。但接着让我（你知道的）觉得可能会成为这次对话第二部分的内容，大约一周后，就是所有的性能分析，你用 NCU 做了大量的工作，我相信，来测量这个指标和那个指标。那些东西就好像我用的是 NSIS，不是一直用，但也相当频繁。是 NCU，不是 N-C-O。是 NCU 吗？
I mean, I've never, I've never heard it said that way in my life. I always say N-C-U. Yeah, because N-C-U. I mean, do you say N-S-Y-S? No, because that has a good, that has a good pronunciation. N-SIS sounds good. NICU? NICU stands for the neonatal incubator.
我的意思是，我这辈子从来没听人那样说过。我一直都说 NCU。对，因为 NCU。我的意思是，你会说 NSYS 吗？不会，因为那个发音好听。NSIS 听起来不错。那 NICU（尼库）？NICU 代表新生儿重症监护室。
It's like where the babies that need help in the hospital go. Well, you know, the kernels need help. Let me, because I've been saying this lot in our tutorials, Nvidia has two different profilers for the compute side of things. Insight Systems gives you an eagle-eyes view of everything that's going on in your program. It's a sampling profiler, so it looks at what's happening to every stage of your profile, of your program. And then it builds up, just like in an audio editor, a bunch of different tracks showing
就像医院里需要帮助的婴儿去的地方。好吧，你知道的，内核也需要帮助。让我说一下，因为我在我们的教程里经常这样说，英伟达针对计算方面有两个不同的性能分析器。Insight Systems 可以让你对程序中发生的一切有一个宏观的鸟瞰视角。它是一个采样分析器，所以它会观察你的程序的每个阶段正在发生什么。然后它会建立起，就像在音频编辑器里一样，一堆不同的音轨，显示
what every process and thread is doing at any given point in time. It is great for identifying I.O. and memory movement bottlenecks, concurrency issues, et cetera, looking at overall utilization. And it has relatively low overhead. But Insight Compute is a kernel level profiler. So it is a tool for profiling a single individual kernel or operation or multiple different kernels and then looking at those results. It can collect a bunch of different hardware performance metrics like, for example, L2
在任何给定的时间，每个进程和线程都在做什么。它非常适合识别 I/O 和内存传输瓶颈、并发问题等，并查看整体利用率。而且它的开销相对较低。但 Insight Compute 是一个内核级别的性能分析器。所以它是一个用于分析单个内核或操作，或者多个不同内核然后查看这些结果的工具。它可以收集一堆不同的硬件性能指标，比如，例如
cash performance information like L2 cash misses or things like how many sectors are utilized out of every L2 sector that's. trend that's loaded in and also things like how many operations are issued per cycle stuff like that now collecting all these hardware performance metrics is challenging because you can only collect a few of the underlying counters at a time so insight compute will run your kernels multiple different times it'll run your whole program multiple different times so it could be up to you know 40 or 50 times so it has a lot of overhead but it gives you very detailed information insights into the performance of a particular kernel or algorithm in your program.
L2 缓存性能信息，比如 L2 缓存未命中，或者诸如加载的每个 L2 扇区中有多少扇区被利用之类的事情。还有诸如每个周期发出多少操作之类的事情。现在，收集所有这些硬件性能指标具有挑战性，因为你一次只能收集几个底层计数器，所以 Insight Compute 会多次运行你的内核，它会多次运行你的整个程序，所以可能会多达 40 或 50 次，因此它有很多开销，但它为你提供了关于程序中特定内核或算法性能的非常详细的信息和见解。
So yes, you used a lot of these metrics of which, to be honest, like how often, Bryce, do you use NICU? Pretty often. Pretty often? I think I've used it once, and like, I failed to gleam any information from it because I was like, this is too confusing. You should come to one of my classes, Connor. I'll teach you.
所以，是的，你用了许多这样的指标，老实说，布莱斯，你多久用一次 NICU？挺经常的。挺经常？我想我用过一次，然后我没能从中收集到任何信息，因为我觉得这太令人困惑了。康纳，你应该来上我的课。我教你。
I have a whole great, we have a great... I've been at your classes. You never talk about NICU. Oh, no, you haven't been to our classes recently, not in the last year. That's not true. I was in Norway. You were, yes, and we talked extensively about inside compute and inside systems. I think you talked about ENSIS briefly.
我有一门非常棒的……我们有一门棒极了……我上过你的课。你从来没提过 NICU。哦，不，你最近没去上我们的课，过去一年都没有。才没有。我在挪威。是的，我们深入探讨了 Insight Compute 和 Insight Systems。我想你简单地讲了一下 NSIS。
But anyways, I'm not an expert. And so we get to chat about the implementations, the things that you were measuring. And hopefully this will be a fun conversation because we love rotate, obviously, but also informative in terms of like, how do you go from nothing to, designing a GPU algorithm and the things you have to consider. And do you start with ENSIS or do you go straight to Nick you? It sounds so weird. But anyways, over to you, Marco. Now, like a mini-representation of the better code GPU rotate that you gave a week ago.
但无论如何，我不是专家。所以我们得以讨论这些实现，以及你当时正在测量的事情。希望这将是一次有趣的对话，因为我们显然热爱旋转，同时也能提供信息，比如，你如何从无到有，设计一个 GPU 算法以及你必须考虑的事情。你是从 ENSIS 开始，还是直接用 Nick you？听起来太奇怪了。不过无论如何，交给你了，马可。现在，请对一周前你给出的更好代码 GPU 旋转做一个小型演示。
Be sure to check these show notes, either in your podcast app or at ADSP thepodcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a GitHub discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. high quantity. That is the tagline of our podcast. It's not the tagline.
请务必查看这些节目笔记，无论是在你的播客应用中还是在 ADSP thepodcast.com 上，都可以找到我们今天节目中提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个 GitHub 讨论链接，你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听。我们希望你喜欢并度过美好的一天。高数量。这是我们播客的标语。这不是标语。
Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的标语是“带有信息 sprinkles（点缀）的混乱”。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。